i've been in the game a long time
you know uh hustling bustling willing to
dylan
and um i've come a long way
you know and i have to
kind of talk about something that that's
important to me
you know that i kept a secret a long
time kept hidden
that's a mental illness you know but mr
mind state of mind
state of being and um i'm about the uh
i really expect a lecture man of uh not
fitting in
not being a part of and um it was like a
shadow and a follow me
you know through my early years
uh adolescent teenagers and uh
didn't know what it didn't know what it
was couldn't put a finger on it
and um i remember my mom telling me
because i was like 12 years old
she said i think you might need to talk
to somebody so what you mean talk to
somebody
so like a therapist you know when um
that stuck with me i didn't follow her
advice
but i never forget it that she saw
something to me
that i couldn't put a finger on but i
knew it was something that existed with
the side of me
but it was all in my mind it was in my
head so
i had all this stuff going on all these
different thoughts and
feelings in what i did to try to uh
subdue it was uh through drugs and
alcohol
and they worked worked for a minute i
got to escape
my [ __ ] reality but as soon as
i came back down the earth
i was faced with the same old things
that feeling
those thoughts and they ruled me
you know they ruled me i became an
isolator
you know i didn't i couldn't i couldn't
do
what the you know i couldn't do with the
with that what the average normal kids
could i remember um
being scared to death to fill out my
first uh
uh student work work visa you know
when i was uh 15 years old you know i'd
have no help but
i remember just being you know just
scared to death man
to do my first little summer gig man uh
i got my license at 50. i remember way
back then
scared to death to do the written test
man i think i didn't do
i don't i think i didn't take my uh or
tried to take my first uh
driver's written test i think it was
like 27 years old
you know and i flunked then i tried it
again maybe at 30 something
and i didn't pass again so i gave up on
it and that was based on those old
thoughts and those feelings that came
with it
my life has been a roller coaster man uh
just
not wanting to admit that i had a
problem man
um just wanting to fit in just wanting
to get in where i fit in i want to be a
part of
you know wanting to be a normal average
kid so
um i endured this this this roller
coaster ride of uh
prison uh drugs alcohol and homelessness
and that took me on that business cycle
lasted man for
almost 30 years you know one after the
other is like a [ __ ] merry-go-round
here i'll go one
i'll go to the next one and do the next
experience but it was the same old [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] memory go round man and
i was just experiencing all three of
those things
in different orders that was that was
that was my life
[ __ ] call it a lifestyle
i call it i had no choice but i did have
a choice i didn't
i just didn't seek the help that i
needed it was self-available
i was too ashamed man full of guilt
you know what the [ __ ] i got to admit
that i need some [ __ ]
medication to
put my foot in front of each other or be
comfortable
i'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ] man i can't do
it i'mma fight this [ __ ] my own
i'm gonna have the inner strength to get
through this [ __ ]
i'm giving [ __ ] what it is and not
knowing it it was too powerful for me
because it's coming from within me not
from without coming up
from uh outside
all the [ __ ] clothes couldn't
couldn't stop that [ __ ] from going on
with within the inside of me as far as
my mental state
i suggest the part in a [ __ ]
gym on swole
you know filled the park feel strong
and all that [ __ ] like hulk or
something invincible
but i said no chance man
you know and um even in the
relationships i said okay well if i just
meet the right woman i'll settle down
and things to just come together
that [ __ ] didn't work
it's all the things i was going through
as far as the [ __ ] that i was going
through in my mind man i kept that to
myself
those is my my deep dark secrets the
[ __ ]
i [ __ ] think i'm crazy man if i share
some of the things that i was going
through that i was thinking back then
know but i committed suicide
uh and most of the thoughts were like
negative
you know it was it was like what i
couldn't do more so than what i could do
when it came to things that were really
important
getting a [ __ ] job getting an
education
you know things like that man i was
scared to death for the workforce
just to being out there in the world and
being a part of society in that way
i was always behind the [ __ ]
scenes behind the curtain in the cut
trying to find my way i never did want
to be on the front line i don't want the
spotlight on me
just always trying to find a way but i
operated in darkness because that's what
the [ __ ] this was operating on
i couldn't do nothing in the daytime
scared to lead a [ __ ] block my
friends
skipped adventure out on my own
to do something important for me
i remember all the miscellaneous and the
[ __ ] i would take
you know up a tape give it here you know
but give me something important give me
an important task to do
scared to death and i wouldn't do it
appointments
job interviews man i i wouldn't keep
them i wouldn't keep those kind of
appointments
you know did it all here we go again
with the mind playing tricks on me
you know and um it got worse before it
got better
you know so what came with the mental
twist
came the crack came to homelessness
came to prisons the rehabs
and um one day man
i think i was uh in my 30s
never forget 2006. i happened to be on
parole at the time
and i showed up for my monthly report
i'm like check this out man
i'm going to end up back in prison again
i see that [ __ ] coming
it's i see the writing on the wall it's
the same old [ __ ] then there i don't
know i don't give a [ __ ] but i do this
time
i don't want to go in and adore that
[ __ ] again
[Applause]
i need to talk to somebody i need some
help he said have a seat in there
in the lobby and um
man shortly after that i got to talk to
uh two people
dr barker good man and
uh amy kim and she was a social worker
for the department outpatient mental
health
and um they
prescribed me some medication and
obviously
i was reluctant to take it in the
beginning you know but um
i did i said [ __ ] it i try anything to
keep going back to prison
to keep from going [ __ ] crazy
you know just my world was turned upside
down and i knew it man but i just
couldn't help it
because it was a part of my character
makeup
it was more stronger more powerful than
crack all that [ __ ]
and um i really needed some help in that
area man
because i know i was different i knew i
didn't think like the average person
thought
mentally and i didn't feel it physically
like i was
okay like i was just you know i'm good
never felt like i was good good enough
for [ __ ] me give a [ __ ] about
for me
like i let myself down i remember being
in my 20s and 30s my mind is always it
was always on me man you didn't do
enough for yourself
you didn't step up to the plate you
didn't you didn't try enough you didn't
put forth an effort for you
i'm like god damn i know that
the [ __ ] am i supposed to do and i'm
having these conversations with myself
you let your family down again i
disappointed mama
oh they said yes and that [ __ ] was just
compound and a compound demand up here
all my past mistakes all my past
failures
i wouldn't let me live it down i was my
own worst critic
so anybody came into contact i was
criticized i was critical of them in a
relationship
i was hard on myself but i didn't
perfect enough effort
you know i feel sorry for myself but
that didn't light a fire up under my ass
nothing really did it for me
but just that one day man right just got
tired man like [ __ ] man i got that
something has to change man because i
can't change me
my mom and him can't prison can't change
me to the drugs and alcohol and
making me feel the way i should be you
know
[ __ ] i'm going deeply deeper into the
abyss the bottomless pit
so fight that [ __ ] medicine and
it helped
but that old lifestyle behavior and
thinking that
that took receding over so i had to try
different combinations of medicine over
the years
because i still couldn't function i
still couldn't couldn't put
abc or one two three together in order
and um [ __ ] i was diagnosed in
2006 and shortly after that i started
receiving a
ssi into mental health
and um i've been uploading medicine man
for
for a while you know i've tried
different different medications over the
years
and i was reluctant i was hesitant
uh when i feel myself getting better at
times i stopped taking it all together
thinking i could do it
do without it and then short time later
the same old habits became the same old
thought pattern started to pick up
the same old character the wrecks just
kicked in and i felt myself
stumbling and bumbling making the same
mistakes i made 10 15
20 uh years ago you know based on
this my mind playing tricks on me but my
mind wasn't playing tricks on me
my mind just wasn't wired the way i know
a normal average person is
uh
i've learned that i had a fully
conceived man that i needed help i
needed medication but more than
medication i needed
to surround myself with some people who
knew exactly what i was going through
what i was dealing with who could help
guide me along the way i couldn't do
that [ __ ] by myself
just being under medication [ __ ]
[ __ ] around this [ __ ] slug if
you're feeling like a [ __ ]
zombie
you know take my medicine at night wake
up in the morning take about an hour for
that [ __ ] to subside after get up
then i'm able to kind of maneuver so i
need to
and with medication comes side effects
so that's explained to me the common
side effects that come with different
medications and um
what happened was man
i continue to find
the kind of medication that helps me it
helps me uh
be okay with me you know helps me be
able to function
get through my [ __ ] day come with me
and
it's important that i have the the
people
around me who can really help me in that
area where i couldn't help myself
mental illness ain't no [ __ ]
joke
i'm a testament to that and i needed
everybody in my corner to
to show me that because i couldn't see
it i knew it was detrimental
me not being under the under the care
and guidance of some people who knew
what i was going through because i
couldn't diagnose myself
you know but there were some people who
could and they can
pinpoint what was what was the problem
areas
and today i have a therapist
i have a case manager i have a
psychiatrist
who uh uh give me the medicine you know
she she writes off
the scripts for me the prescriptions and
um
all of them play a vital role in my
success man or my failure
because if i don't get the right kind of
medication i'm it's not gonna help me
so they need to be they need to make
sure that the the medication is correct
the dosage is correct the information is
correct
and i've been fortunate in that area
because
my supporting my support my supporting
cast man they're they're they're great
at their jobs
all of them play an important part and
they're [ __ ] great at it
they don't [ __ ] me they're gonna
check and jive they're seriously trying
to help me
be able to live a more fulfilling life
man under the guise of medication man
you know like ain't no ducking and
dodging you know running and hiding
checking driving through this
[ __ ] because it ain't no joke
man
in session so if i'm fully aware that
life concession i have a better chance
of dealing with it
can't [ __ ] play dumb
oh man oh because i've been uh diagnosed
with this so i can act like no i can't
i can't justify that [ __ ] the way i
get down
by being diagnosed with something that
has to do with mental health
i can't use it as a crutch
and i can't look at something negative
that keep me feeling like i'm one for
the straight jacket
i have to see it for what it is a new
way of life a new way of looking at
things
my bad a different way of looking at
things
you know with the help of others in
medication i ain't that a [ __ ]
double dose of some reality that it took
me a long time to look at
and face
yeah man [ __ ]
uh they're running they're running late
on my medicine and uh
i see the the old signs and feelings and
all that [ __ ] coming back
despite i'm in a [ __ ] gym
i'm i'm living on my own and being
responsible taking responsibility
you know i see my sleep patterns not
happening i'm not getting enough sleep
my [ __ ] man i woke up this morning
and i said to myself i can't go into the
day but i'm on my [ __ ] medication
and a [ __ ] phone wrong he says
yeah man we gotta uh call friday
said the nurse tried to deliver your
medication but they had the wrong
telephone number
do we have your uh your information
again please
your address and your number i said
we'll deliver your medication today
between 12 and 2.
sorry for the inconvenience man i hung
up and i cried
just my creator answered me not the [ __ ]
i'm going to know what i'm feeling if
nobody else does
my [ __ ] family can't even
realize what it is the only one who has
the inkling is my mom
but the creator said i got you
wrong like i woke up this morning said i
can't do it
not not what not without the help
and i've been on this ship man up almost
20 years
you know but get let me go
two three let me go a week without my
medication
god damn what a or psychosories
you wouldn't want to see me like that i
wouldn't want to see myself like that
and that's the guy's honest truth and
that's some [ __ ] that people need to
know
what's going on behind the [ __ ]
scenes
not what i put out there but it's a [ __ ]
that you can't see
you know that's that's that's that's
what time it is that's what i'm dealing
with
the [ __ ] that i've been living with for
most of my life all my life
not being your average joe not being a
wire like like like everybody else man
but you know and um
man i saw i remember i used to think to
myself man god why
why did why was i born man i might have
to be born not just
being different man i think i've been
feeling different why can't i just be
like the average [ __ ] man
just go through life man and find my
bumps and all that [ __ ] man
and they're doing my bumps and all that
[ __ ] along the way
you know like you got to add some
[ __ ] to the equation already
but with the race and and the ghetto and
being poor
and all that other [ __ ] plus the mental
help god
man i need a break man can you cut me
some mouth up and slap
and he did and he continues to
when i hit him he comes through to say
today well i can't say my [ __ ]
self
so like i said before this is a serious
topic
and it it needs to be addressed and it
needs to be dealt with man
and for those who suffer from mental
health uh
schizophrenia depression bipolar
you know there's mother [ __ ] help
available man we got to suffer go
through some [ __ ] by yourself
that's up available man you know and um
it ain't easy admitting it and sometimes
it ain't easy
just going through it man the process
but a beast
i'd rather give it a shot than not try
at all
you know because uh the best thing
i could have did for myself was that day
when i was in the parole office and i
asked for help
because it was always there always ready
for me i just need to step up to the
plate
you know and make that call and i did
it's the best thing i've ever done
best he says your best choice but it
hasn't been easy
you know still trial and error even
today i'm still trying to get a handle
on the day-to-day thing without my
medication
or different circumstances or problems
coming up and how i deal with them
you know i don't tuck my tail now i
don't run no more
i'm not saying it's easy still got to
deal with some [ __ ] uncomfortable things
difficult things
but um at least i have a a a fighting
chance today
you know medicine helps and i have some
people i can call that could help me
to show me the way when i came and i
just felt like i just can't go on no
more
you know so uh yeah you know it's
it's uh it's real uh
it's sad it's funny you know it's
exhilarating and all that [ __ ]
you know all those things there's some
but the bottom line is man
um i'm glad i got that help and i'm glad
it's still available to me
you know i can pick up that
[ __ ] call i'm in the phone and
make a call
they got a lot of places around here i
can go to you know
different uh services that are available
to me just like the [ __ ] gym
and so forth for so long
you know i got some services people you
know that are
there you know lend a helping hand
because too many people are suffering
and they don't have to in that area
because they just don't want to admit
you know so i admit that [ __ ] and
admitting that [ __ ] i'm
i'm being set free from the way i think
and how i feel
that's been dealing that's i've been
dealing with for most of my life
so uh on that note that's all i got for
you
thank you thank you
mental health is probably what's really
behind a lot of drug use isn't it
that's what i see because you can blame
drugs all you want
if you really break it down yeah that's
it mental health is what's going on
behind the drug use yes yeah and then
the
childhood trauma and all that behind
that
but
creating a little more understanding
with all these talks
you going to the gym no my medicine's
coming
between 12 and 2. then you go to the gym
first things first